SPEAKER: Do you remember
when we used to walk down here
and all the neighbors
used to stare at us?
And we used to be...
-And we would just be,
"Pumping."
-Runway.
SPEAKER: They would look at us
like we were circus freaks,
but you can tell
they enjoyed it.
SPEAKER 2: The minute
I got off on 14th Street,
you could hear
the clickety-clack of the heels.
SPEAKER 3: The life,
the light, the shadows.
KRISTEN LOVELL: They called
14th Street "The Stroll,"
and that was our turf.
SPEAKER 4:
Some people choose sex work
because they want to.
Being a trans woman in the 80s,
a lot of us
did not have a choice.
People were not hiring
people that looked like me.
Trans life in general,
it was difficult.
I wanted to make people
understand the reality
of our lives
through storytelling.
The one issue today that
obsesses New Yorkers. Crime.
SPEAKER 5: The trannies
were out on the street 24/7.
It was really
a very bad situation.
I mean, they think
I'm out here to murder people
instead of have sex with them
for money.
SPEAKER 6:
We didn't know who's who.
You know, everybody's a client.
I actually gave fellatio
to a man who was a cop.
And after I was done doing
his deed, he arrested me.
Whether it was from
the police or the john,
there was a lot of violence.
I almost got killed by a john
who dragged me
for half a block in his car.
SPEAKER 7:
We were on the front line with
the gay and lesbian community
but you're not doing anything to
help me from getting attacked.
We knew we were freaks to them.
(SOBBING) I can't even
believe it, but it's, like,
the things we had to do.
SPEAKER 8:
The trans community has been
in survival mode forever.
It's important that we all
get an opportunity to...
thrive.
We've fought to be where we are.
SPEAKER 9: The system
never gave us resources.
We created the resources.
We have always been last.
That's not gonna
happen anymore.
SPEAKER 10: You owe it
to every trans woman before you
and everyone after you
to keep pushing.
LOVELL: We were pushed out
of the neighborhood years ago.
I was determined to make a film
about The Stroll
before we're gone.
SPEAKER 11:
-No.
-No, we're talkin'
about our lives.
Out here before this
became this.
SPEAKER 11: I remember that.
-Ooh!
-(LAUGHTER)
He said, "I remember that."
I'm sure you do.
What's your name.
(LAUGHTER)
SPEAKER 12: You still got it.